let's look at the CSV file containing our
Aadhaar enrollment data once again. Each row has
a number of columns such as, registrar, enrollment
agency, state, district, Aadhaar generated, enrollment rejected, and a
bunch of other information. If we want to count
the number of Aadhaar generated per district. The
columns that we're most interested in are district
and Aadhaar generated. Can you fill in the missing
pieces of the mapper? So if you wanted to complete this
job using the mapper programming model, we would need to write
a mapper and reducer. Why don't you give it a try.
Here is the skeleton of a mapper for this job. We
go through every single line in the input. In this case,
it's going to be our CSV file containing all of the
rows and our Aadhar-generated data. You're going to have to go
through each line, which will be a list of comma-separated values.
The header row will be included. Took a nice each
row using the commas and emit a key value pair
containing the district and the number of Aadhhar generated separated
by a tab. Make sure that each row has the
correct number of tokens and make sure it's not the
header row. In order to count the number of Aadhaar
generated per district using map reduce, we'll also have to
write a reducer. Here's the skeleton of a reducer function
that you'll fill in. We initialize aadhaar_generated to 0,
and set old_key to None. You'll cycle through the list
of key value pairs emitted by your mapper, and print
out each key once, along with the total number of
Aadhaar generated, separated by a tab. You can assume that
the list of key value pairs will be ordered by
key. Make sure that each key value pair is formatted
correctly before you process it. Here's a sample final key
value pair. Gujarat\t5.0.